2550 cancers sont diagnostiqués chez les
enfants et adolescents chaque année en
france le docteur sylvie nathan sont
hélas chef du service pédiatrique situé
au 7e étage du centre hospitalier de
versailles
tu as passé une bonne semaine ouais est
ce que tu as des choses particulières à
raconter depuis la semaine dernière ce
que tu as été malade ce qu'une chose
n'ont rien de spécial pape hier peta a
pas eu la grippe à l'âge de 4 ans
gérault a perdu la vue suit un irm le
diagnostic tombe gérault a une tumeur
cérébrale
un gliome des nerfs optiques tu respires
fort parfait il a eu il a eu plusieurs
cycles de chimio sur un non pas le même
deux ans la première fois et il a été
opéré
déjà deux fois à necker et il est suivi
toutes les trois mois il a une irm et en
fonction de l'évolution de la tumeur on
décide de reprendre une chimio ou pas
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu une chimiothérapie
qu'il continuera jusqu'en novembre 2019
à seulement 10 ans le petit garçon est
très lucide sur sa situation
parfois j'ai eu plusieurs rendez vous
par semaine mais sinon j'y vais au moins
une fois par semaine je me jette un oeil
ou chimio je respire et je je je pense
est quelque chose que j'aime bien malgré
la maladie géraud à des occupations d'un
enfant de son âge
pressés comme des dominos mai mais il
faut par exemple payer deux couleurs
commune qui se touchent et si ce n'est
pas facile
le cancer de jehro une lutte quotidienne
depuis plusieurs années qui a provoqué
un véritable chamboulement pour ses
proches notamment dans la vie
professionnelle de sa mère c'est un peu
le ciel qui nous tombe sur la tête
le quotidien as et c'est vivre avec un
enfant qui hospitalisée très
régulièrement avec beaucoup de beaucoup
de rendez vous donc voilà je ne
travaille pas je m'occupe de mes enfants
et ça me permet d'être disponible pour
géraud d'aidé qu'il a besoin
le service pédiatrique du centre
hospitalier de versailles prend en
charge une vingtaine d'enfants pour des
cancers six à huit jeunes sont reçus par
jour pour des soins en ambulatoire et
ils sont suivis en partenariat avec les
services de cancérologie pédiatrique
parisien alors le premier type de cancer
le plus fréquent ce sont les leucémies
lanfranchi les cancers du sang des
anomalies des cellules sanguines qui
prolifèrent donc ça c'est le premier
premier type de cancer chez l'enfant
dans ce service pédiatrique fresque
murale animaux avec comme but faire
oublier la maladie aux enfants car les
cancers pédiatriques se développent plus
rapidement que chez les adultes
le combat continue pour les médecins
familles et enfants